on est en communication avec la mienne
charlebois consultante en relations
publiques conférencière et auteure et
journaliste est aussi avec à la cei
donne pas ce que je prononce bien elle
est une étudiante de 22 ans
il a terminé son baccalauréat en
sciences politiques avec une mineure à
l'étude du moyen-orient à l'université
mcgill ici à montréal et va commencer
son droit surtout des endroits en
septembre aussi merci d'avoir accepté
c'est un produit commenté les goûts
merci à vous et au canada international
bonjour mais salut est-ce que je prends
donc bien votre nom oui comment donc
selon plusieurs analystes plusieurs
médias aussi le liban dont vous êtes
originaire lui la pire crise économique
politique et sociale de son histoire
j'aimerais pour commencer savoir dès
votre point de vue des baux deux points
de vue différents indistincte comment
vous expliquer un peu comment vous vivez
et y expliquer aussi cette crise
actuelle au liban
tu comment serait peut-être pas là bien
évidemment étant plus âgés qu'eux alors
là j'ai vu beaucoup de crise au liban
plusieurs à répétition je peux vous dire
que celle ci est la pire de tous les
temps en tout cas de mon vivant en
disant c'est une parce que c'est une
crise économique financière sanitaire
social c'est une crise politique et le
tout est arrivé en même temps évidemment
lakovic n'a pas été du tout c'est une
crise qui arrive aussi appris une
révolution qui a commencé le 17 octobre
au liban qui nous a donné beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'espoir et
qui a montré encore et encore et encore
que le peuple libanais est un peuple
extraordinaire résilient positif qui
veut prendre les choses en main qui veut
changer son pays
et franchement si ce n'était que du poc
le pays serait dix fois mieux que qu'il
ne l'est maintenant
or il est entre les mains du classe
politique corrompue et est mauvaise il
faut dire aussi que il ya un problème
qui est nouveau on n'a jamais eu de même
à travers la guerre civile que j'ai eu
le malheur de vivre
on a on n'a jamais eu de problèmes de
pauvreté et c'est de famille
de la classe moyenne et presque effacé
on a aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle des
nouveaux pauvres haut niveau donc le
chômage est à son pire et ce qui fait
très peur c'est que l'avenir même les
gens les plus optimistes et plus
combattants les plus positifs ce peuple
là qu'elle fait la révolution et un
petit peu pessimiste donc on est tous
très très inquiet je laisse la parole à
l'ats parce que alors avec ses
connaissances en sciences politiques
elle a une vue scientifique jugé
complètement d'accord avec toi damien et
je pense que le problème au niveau et
d'un problème politique
donc le clientélisme le système
confessionnel de partage de pouvoir et
aussi une classe politique est très
corrompue et incompétente sont à
l'origine de cette crise sur l'économie
dans quel cadre politique par exemple a
commis depuis 2008 l'un avant que
l'électricité 24 24 aujourd'hui cette
promesse est vide comme beaucoup
d'autres commerces et aussi les secteurs
de l'électricité aujourd'hui il est
responsable de la moitié de la ville du
pays
donc voilà combien que quatre politique
incompétente en tenant compte des
incompétents et justement je voulais
aussi parler la question de liberté
d'expression parce que ça a été évoquée
par plusieurs médias une crise de
liberté d'expression en a parlé
évidemment de la crise sanitaire de la
crise économique de la crise politique
dont vous parlez particulièrement mais
il ya aussi la question de la liberté
d'expression radio-canada justement
publié hier un texte qui présentait
plusieurs témoignages des gens qui me
ses livres en plus de tout
c'était dix ont créé une situation
particulièrement difficile dans les rues
dans les maisons et c'est avec la classe
politique et il ya aussi cette
répression
en ce qui concerne le liberté des
paroles pas levé les serrant la réponse
gaza mais en passant je tiens à
remercier profondément radio canada qui
n'a jamais lâché le liban et qui prend
toujours le temps de mettre la lumière
sur les événements là bas d'une façon
neutre et d'une façon très
professionnelle et ça c'est vraiment au
nom de tout le peuple libanais
les remercie parce que la pire chose ce
serait de tomber dans l'oubli dans
l'oubli de l'actualité qui on peut plus
être occupés dans l'actualité
cette année on va je laisse à la parler
d'exploit de la liberté d'expression qui
est assez grave aussi oui parlement tout
un sujet très alarmant je pense que le
liban est l'un des pays arabes les plus
libres et mais depuis août 2015 et la
crise d'ordures et les manifestations
qui ont dénoncé la mannschaft politique
qu'on a dénoncé en octobre 2020 les cas
de diffamation qui ont été investigués
par le bureau du circuit de cible du
cyber-crime a augmenté de façon
alarmante donc juste pour donner un sens
selon human rights watch en 2018 le
bourg ont investigué 1451 de 10 de cas
de diffamation
85 % de plus qu'en 2007 et 325 points de
plus qu'en 2004
donc c'est alarmant c'est dangereux dans
une entrevue avec coty avec human right
watch le journaliste libanais
il ya trouvé ici a dit au liban il y a
un fort esprit de liberté et pas assez
de démocratie que l'a complètement
on comprend que les lois sur l'injure
l'autre âge et la diffamation sont là
pour protéger les personnes dont
l'arrestation a été a été injustement
termine et le problème c'est que cette
classe politique qui est corrompue et
incompétente
elle utilise ces lois là pour se
protéger et pour faire taire les
journalistes les voix critiques qui eux
jouent un rôle primordial dans le
dévoilement de la compétition en plus de
ta les lois qui autorisent
l'emprisonnement des individus pour
avoir critiqué des personnes dans le
gouvernement sont incompatibles avec les
obligations internationales du liban en
matière de protection de la liberté
d'expression qui est doublement
dangereux juste pour donner un exemple
il ya l'avocat à la tête qui a été
violemment il ya quelques jours et les
agresseurs ont utilisé une voiture qui
appartenaient au ministère des affaires
sociales et du tourisme ya beaucoup de
preuves
le canada et le liban à gabes ont une
relation de longue date une relation
assez étroite
il ya plusieurs haut niveau aussi de la
société mais aussi il faut dire que la
communauté libanaise qu'après ça le
groupe ethnique arabes les plus
importants au canada et un grand nombre
de canadiens vivent au liban au liban
pendant je voulais savoir qu'est ce que
le canada vous parliez tout à l'heure de
la communauté internationale mais qu'est
ce que le canada où vous habitez
l'amiante depuis tant d'années peut
faire pour dans le contexte politique et
social actuel dans votre pays d'origine
je je suis content de vous parler mais
de pays le canada d'abord le canada à
une diaspora libanaise qui est
magnifique qui est magnifique et
contribuer socialement économiquement
moralement médicalement on a des tops
médecins qui sont dit mané il ya des
fondations des charités qui ont été
organisés pour aider par exemple je
pense à la fondation du cancer du sein
ainsi de ce quartier fabert
il ya le libanais ne passe pas ailleurs
calmement et gentiment le libanais
contribuent-ils fait la fête ça c'est
vrai mais il contribue à la société à
l'économie il paye cette taxe avec
plaisir
en général ça se passe très bien et je
dois dire qu'au canada ça se passe
particulièrement bien c'est un très bel
communauté dont je suis extrêmement fier
maintenant pourquoi
qu'est ce que le canada peut faire et
après je vais vous dire pourquoi pas
seulement le canada pourquoi parce que
c'est un petit pays au fin fond du monde
on pourrait l'oublier parce que c'est le
plus beau pays du monde
là c'est autre chose c'est mon coeur qui
parle il faut qu'ils puissent aider le
liban à obtenir une neutralité avec le
soutien de l'onu bien sûr dans cette
région parce que les conflits régionaux
on le veuille ou pas nous affecte depuis
jeudi nous les libanais nous affecte
depuis trop longtemps
à chaque fois que d'ailleurs on le dit
en arabe en blaguant quand l'iran
éternue quand israël tous quand la
russie se lève du mauvais pied
il est temps que ce qu'on soit pas et
fluence est à ce point par les conflits
régionaux et que tous les conflits
régionaux passe par non parce que c'est
facile parce que c'est pratique parce
que c'est un terrain fertile pour ça ça
c'est 2-1 2-2 aider les libanais à tuer
le système qui est en place et aider les
libanais à prendre le pouvoir
s'il ya une expertise quelconque ou un
savoir quelconque donner ce pouvoir
entre les mains du peuple le peuple est
génial il est génial il est fort et duke
est solide il a la bonne volonté et il
connaît bien son pays sait c'est quoi le
bien de son pays et des a dénoncé le cet
argent qui a disparu l'argent du peuple
c'est l'argent du peuple c'est pas
l'argent des politiciens qui a disparu
dans des banques étrangères
je veux bien qu'ils aient le secret
bancaire internationale mais dans ce cas
là il ya bien eu wikileaks il ya bien eu
des dénonciations il ya bien eu des
dossiers qui sont sortis de leur boîte
il est temps qu'on voit il est où cet
argent dans quelle banque en suisse
c'est quoi les comptes qui a fait
qu'elle virement il ya eu d'événements
qui ont énorme qui ont été fait en
catastrophe et en urgence des cas eu la
révolution c'est quand même un peu
louche c'est l'argent du peuple
c'est pas l'argent des politiciens le
politicien un vrai politicien il est au
service de son peuple il est employé
chez son peuple
alan ou voulais vous poser une question
plus pointus par rapport à votre
expertise parce que vous savez un
baccalauréat en sciences politiques une
mineure comme je disais en études du
moyen-orient justement la position
géopolitique du liban dans la région est
très particulière
mais dites nous comment voyez-vous
justement cette position-là par rapport
aux pays dans lesquels but et maintenant
que c'est le canada donc qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que peut arriver dans cette
perspective là que le liban a toujours
été bien avant la guerre civile et
pendant la guerre civile comme une proxy
pour les poulets plémy les l'iran les
etats-unis la russie ce procès il a donc
ont été retrouvés déchiquetés par ces
trois pays
donc il ya des gens au liban qui veulent
qui se trouve plus à l'aise par exemple
et en étant proche d'êta vionnet
d'autres veulent ils iront là la chine
d'aristide
donc je pense que c'est ces problèmes
géopolitiques en difficulté on divisait
le liban mais aussi le peuple libanais
par sassou des démineurs religieuse pas
aussi musulman chrétien donc aggraver la
situation confessionnel au liban et le
rôle de la religion et la politique et
donc dangereux mais est ce que vous
voyez le un rôle pour les canadiens ce
contexte-là vous dans ce contexte parce
que vous parlez de trois autres grandes
puissances économiques le canada n'est
pas sur une puissante du sans-souci
grande que la chine ou la russie ou les
etats-unis mais quand même un pays
développés pays qui fait partie du g7
donc le canada également le canada a une
expertise c'est à dire je ne pense pas
qu'ils ont le
pouvoir d'intervenir de taper sur les
doigts des états unis ou la russie
le voit un peu on le voit un peu avec
nos frontières ici pour des sujets comme
le bois comme on a eu on a eu des
petites embarcations et disons que nos
voisins américains ont actuellement un
leader politique qui est
particulièrement volatil et passons là
dessus bazire alors je pense que le
canada peut faire quelque chose mais
aussi le liban a ôté un collant donc le
canada peut sûrement par exemple dans le
monétaire international va exiger des
réformes
est ce que la classe politique corrompue
au liban n'a pas exigé des réformes
donc on a besoin d'une force extérieure
comme le fonds monétaire international
pour exiger des réformes
ils ont été de le faire arrivant à
travers le secteur de l'électricité
ils viendront on a besoin de cette force
extérieure canada-états-unis n'importe
quel spectateur mais en même temps le
liban aussi un rôle à jouer
il doit exiger ces récents et il doit
faire ses récentes et une reconstruction
de saab est donc oui on a besoin de
l'aide extérieure mais aussi on noiera
rentrée daily mail les libanais entre
eux mais ça je dois vous dire qu'on est
là permets-moi de on l'a fait c'est à
dire qu on le fait et on l'a fait mais
aujourd'hui vous avez d'ailleurs la
révolution d'octobre 2010 9 a été
extraordinaire ça a été une leçon pour
la planète
les femmes étaient dans la rue ça a été
une révolution 2 féminine surtout mais
d'une force de vie et des sports
extraordinaire mais là aujourd'hui le
peuple effet comment voulez vous qu'on
continue à se battre et qu'on fasse des
réformes et qu'on écrive des réformes
est grand qu'on mène tout un pays
quand tous les jours en et le peuple est
bafouée insulté humilié affamés on l'a
on l'a privé de denrées de base de
denrées alimentaires de l'électricité
les routes sont problématiques
le chômage on les a privés vous avez
aujourd'hui des pères de famille il ya
eu trois quatre suicides qui ne sait ni
jamais vu c'est pas un pc on n'a pas
tellement de celui-ci boniments c'est
pas c'est pas la gaude problème mais
parce qu'ils peuvent pas nourrir leurs
enfants
donc est ce que le canada ne va pas
aller régler tous les problèmes du liban
je suis d'accord avec la lazio
lamia charlebois à la z1 merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de me parler de ce qui
est évidemment très passionnant pour
vous deux
c'est de cette situation au liban au
liban nous touche personnellement vous
tous chers dans ce nouveau centre a
désiré mais vous êtes ici au canada
appuie donc que vous vivez un peu sa dé
loin donc cette distance aussi peu
difficile donc j'apprécie beaucoup que
vous ayez accepté de participer à ce
très bel hommage si vous permettez à 20
secondes
un dernier mot pour alors et un dernier
mot pour moi parce que l'un des messages
envoyés à nos pays
allez allez vous inspire étage merci
beaucoup pour cette opportunité paloma
je voulais juste dire que une des plus
belles caractéristiques du peuple
libanais à mon avis et par étudiant
je la vois fait résiliente dont les deux
mon papa consultant à la banque chaque
semaine ou qu'on aurait d'argent malgré
les restrictions
cela va aussi dans les es2 maman qui qui
sourit qui est heureux et fier de l'être
malgré tout et je la vois aussi qu'à
montréal dans le dernière qui se bat et
se bat et se bat et il ne cesse
d'inspirer à se battre pour un niveau
meilleur mais je pense que cette forte
résilience cache beaucoup de blessures
d'espoir driver et de l et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui cette résidence est
devenu comme un prix village emploi
parce que beaucoup de gens au liban
n'arrive quid à l'être le peuple
libanais et crûment épuisé aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup
moi mon dernier message c'est je
l'envoie à tourner toute ma famille tous
mes amis et tout mon peuple au liban
je suis extrêmement fier d'eux je
n'aurais pas voulu naître dans aucun
autre pays au monde
je suis très fier d'être aussi
canadienne j'aurais pas choisi un autre
pays au monde
en tout cas pas la chine on va passer là
dessus et je leur souhaite beaucoup de
courage et on les lâche pas et on se bat
avec eux à l'étranger aussi partout au
monde et dans nos pays adoptif
donc on continue et on n'arrête pas et
je suis sûr que le canada peut donner un
coup de pouce et le fonds monétaire
international
ce compte là dessus alors merci beaucoup
beaucoup merci à vous merci beaucoup à
la merci beaucoup donc on va c'est
peut-être un autre moment vraiment à
découvrir
merci beaucoup au revoir